ma chaîne youtube est la première chaîne
en france a dépassé les 4 millions
d'abonnés c'est un record et c'est
surtout votre record
ah c'est pas moi qui ai cliquer sur
s'abonner c'est vous c'est vous qui
l'avez fait alors bravo je vous
applaudis
vous pouvez vous applaudir aussi d'art
votre enfant ou pas pour vous remercier
je vais pas simplement vous dire merci
je vais répondre à vos questions puisque
vous avez été très nombreux à me
demander la suite de cette vidéo
alors c'est parti quelle caméra
utilises-tu j'ai changé pas mal de
caméras j'utilisais d'abord à l'iphone 4
un lumix gf2 un lumix g 5 est maintenant
j'utilise une canonique savoir je peux
pas vous la montrer parce que balaie
devant moi sauf si j'utilise un miroir
voilà ça ressemble à ça dit plus bonjour
combien de personnes sont là pour
t'aider à faire des vidéos alors ça je
vous ai jamais montrer ce qu'ils sont
des rats la caméra alors yannick haut à
la caméra samantha au maquillage iajour
mon coiffeur au son il y a personne
je suis tout seul pour faire mes vidéos
tout seul
quelle est ta plus grande fierté bah ma
plus grande fierté c'est vous tout
simplement
emad pourquoi tu dis toujours pourquoi
c'est vrai ça pourquoi
[ __ ] il a raison sais-tu jouer d'un
instrument de musique
alors je suis pas très très bon mais je
joue de la batterie dès que j'ai deux
minutes
ce tweak mcdo ou là alors ça je ne peux
pas répondre à cette question
sinon je vais me faire beau écouter par
la moitié des internautes c'est un petit
peu la guerre entre les deux donc je ne
répondrai jamais je suis désolé mcdo en
cours de français participe passé
participe présent partie cyprien ton
premier mot quand tu étais bébé ah ouais
ça tombe bien ça parce que j'ai même la
vidéo en fait monarchie
constitutionnelle au ainsi pris un
sauvage à paris
je n'ai pas ce pokémon crapuleux
[Musique]
et
est-ce que des fois tu as envie de te
taper dessus
non non non non je t'ai eue je t'ai eue
regarde la bâche un sac de bâle où ça
non
de quelle couleur sont tes yeux comme
tout le monde
orange est ce que la blague scie
sauteuse était marrant pour toi dans la
vidéo vous testez mario sur wii où cette
blague ne me dit rien ce n'est pas ce
n'était pas les intérêts c'était
quelqu'un qui me ressemble et qui est
fait cette blague ça c'est pas mon genre
moi moi j'ai un humour qui est plus plus
subtile des séries préférées alors
backing band game of thrones le destin
de lisa
c'est une blague la plus belle grimace
alors ça c'est marrant parce que quand
je suis devant un miroir je m'amuse à
faire plein de cry macho c'est très
bizarre j'en ai plein je vous en fait
vous choisissez vous
mais sinon j'ai des amis un faux pas
croire parce que ps4 xbox one
allez je m'en bats les couilles puisque
j'ai les deux concluent un jour nous
mettre le bêtisier ou le making of dans
tes vidéos
alors alors là vous allez avoir une
petite surprise dans quelques jours je
ne dis rien je l' ai quand même dit mais
c'est pas grave tu aimes le swag watts
et mais le swag c'est quoi cette
question ça se mange le swag vous
aimerez tu le plus à l'est dans le monde
ces formules un peu bizarrement mais
c'est le japon depuis j'y suis allé
l'année dernière je pense qu'à une seule
chose tous les jours je pense à y
retourner
j'aimerais même y vivre quelques
quelques temps si c'était possible mais
ça va être un peu compliqué comment tu
fais pour avoir quelqu'un qui te
ressemble vraiment dans tes vidéos tu as
un jumeau bah oui effectivement j'ai un
j'ai un frère jumeau salue bien vu
d'aegis thouars licorne et va dans ta
ville comme ça t'es cap ou pas c'est
quoi ces questions de mairie
c'est pas la viande de cheval j'espère
jamais je fais la bise allez à bientôt
[Musique]
bon
et encore bravo à vous quatre millions
c'est dingue et à très vite
[Musique]
avant de se quitter j'ai une petite
surprise pour vous vous êtes 4 millions
vous le méritez
je lance aujourd'hui la nouvelle version
de mon application iphone et android
vous m'avez demandé une version ipad
c'est chose faite waouh
il y a un tout nouveau design il ya
aussi mes vidéos cyprien gaming comme ça
ça fait deux fois plus de vidéos à
regarder
j'ai fait des nouveaux dessins pour le
sipri g et surtout il ya une nouvelle
sandbox
profitez-en le prix a diminué
l'application est passé de zéro à zéro
euro
[Musique]